indium is a very soft metal
I have no sample here it melts at about
150 degrees or so so this is a sample of
indium it's a really really quite nice
chemical reactor mikhyl element this one
we can use it for lots and lots of
selective types of catalysis but
generally when it's forming a complex
with lots of other organic ligands but
here we can see a really nice sample of
indium and this is 99.9% pure but it's a
metal which has suddenly become very
much more expensive because it's oxide
is transparent to light but will conduct
electricity so it is indium oxide that
you find on every LCDs display here this
one rather old computer and here is an
old-fashioned computer the LCD display
was quite small and gradually they've
got bigger and bigger and therefore the
this demand for indium oxide is more and
more and probably you're watching this
video clip through a thin layer of
indium oxide the sample although it's
very small it's 5 grams so it's a really
really dense metal very very expensive
very very valuable as well but
indian-made also used as a soldier for
soldiering various metals together and
it's also quite useful if I used it in
my youth when we were making
low-temperature apparatus and we wanted
to screw two things together and get a
nice seal in between them you could
screw them together with a thin sheet of
indium and that almost welded them
together so indium wire it's very very
malleable very very soft and very easy
to form into shapes I'm not going to
touch it though because it will cause
some significant problems for me because
it does cause toxicity if it comes into
contact with the skin so lovely piece of
indium wire